Jim Moore the former UCLA head coach you
can see Jim throughout the week on the
NFL Network's path to the draft Monday
through Friday at 6:00 Eastern leading
up to the 2018 NFL Draft and joining us
in the Continental Tire Coach's Corner
good morning coach how are you I'm great
I'm doing okay but I'm a little worried
about you you seem to be stirring it up
you know maybe you're just being honest
here but you know you're you're getting
some headlines there if that was your
goal you're getting headlines yeah I
think that's really interesting you know
I didn't I've been talking a lot about
Josh and I've been really clear and I've
been really consistent and I've been
very very I think complimentary towards
him as a matter of fact I think if you
go back and look at anything that I've
said it's all been very very positive
and it should be very positive I love
the kid I'm not talking about him I
think he's a tremendous young man and I
think that as you know because you've
done it to me before dance
goddang identity or things can be can be
misrepresented at times when people
decide to edit in a certain way I think
what first guard the most attention was
when I had mentioned that I thought Sam
Donald was maybe a better fit for for
the Cleveland Browns and you know I'll
stand by that you know and I look back I
look at the work that Hugh Jackson did
with a with a guy like Andy Dalton and
his style of play and the success that
they had at Cincinnati in eighties a
little bit more sand Arnold so by saying
that some buddies are fit for team than
another is in no way being negative
towards Josh I love Josh I love talking
about him I love pointing out all the
positives and and and helping to clear
up some of the misrepresentations about
him and I said that he needed to be
challenged intellectually which he does
this is a tremendously intelligent young
man and I think tremendously intelligent
people function the best when they're
challenged intellectually when you
continually stimulate them
intellectually and that's how Josh is he
wants to know
why he's you know to crap about the
millennial statement but I would think
what people need to understand is that
he's got been coaching college football
for six years and was 120 kids on my
team between the ages of 17 and 22 plus
I have four kids and I understand that
generation I think pretty well and they
have a propensity now to ask the
question why and they don't say it in a
derogatory condescending or
disrespectful way at all they just want
to understand what you're asking them to
do and that is Josh and when you are
able to tell them why then they embrace
it they're more engaged and and and they
activate better and so but I know that
the coaches you know coach that that we
were probably reading into it too much
that's why I wanted to have you on but
but let me go back glad you asked me to
come on so that I could talk about Josh
and leatherpuss I love talking about it
but let me ask you about Cleveland
because as it was spun it felt like Sam
Darnell but but it was spun in a way
that says Sam darn 'old is the
blue-collar type guy that would fit in
with Cleveland with that city you know
that maybe that's not Josh was
reportedly on record as saying that he
didn't want to play for Cleveland I
don't know if it felt like maybe you
were saying you know what let me help
Josh not end up in Cleveland why why
would he work in New York with that
media and he wouldn't work in Cleveland
with the blue-collar town that was the
curiosity it's not a media I'm not
working where the environment of New
York as opposed to the environment of no
it's not the environment of the city its
environment the team it's it's Hugh
Jackson and Andy Dalton you know that
connection right there I think we'd all
agree that Andy Dalton is is kind of a
blue-collar worker it's it's a city or
if you wanted me to connect it to a city
you know the Cleveland Browns it's it's
I'm not being disrespectful eiga today
struggled of late if they struggle here
late and so Sam
you know the way his style of play it's
just it just to me it just fit and I
think that Josh fits another place I
think it's that's why guys get drafted
to certain teams there's a fit there's
the best player available there's so
many factors that go into it but you
know I just think josh is you know I
said it yesterday he's not only the best
quarterback in the draft I think he's
the best player he's gonna come in in my
opinion he's an immediate starter at at
the next level and he's going to be
successful as immediate immediate
starters the next level what does he do
better than Sam Darnell I'm not gonna
get into comparison to those two well
you're an analyst now better no I'm a
advocate of Josh and Colton Miller and
Matt Dickerson and Jordan Lasky and
those guys I'll tell you what I think
Josh does well josh has a tremendous arm
and I'll say arm Talent he can make
every throw that is required to make to
be a great NFL player he's got
tremendous pocket mobility which means
he can slip and slide in the pocket he
is more effective outside the pocket
then people would think you know he does
have athleticism the move and escape
he's fearless he's competitive he sees a
field incredibly well he would come to
the sidelines after a play I'm sorry
after a series Nika diagnosed every play
could be a 12 13 play drive and he can
tell you what happened on every single
play with every single player he learns
very quickly he loves to be coached hard
he loves to be challenged he you know he
wants to put the ball exactly where it's
supposed to be foot so you know you
don't just tell Josh hey throw a curl
you tell me you throw a curl you put it
on you know the left number and that's
what Josh is gonna try to put it and
he's he's competitive as I'll get out
and I'll you go back and look at the
Texas A&M game this year when we were
down and and if he didn't rise up and
carry his team to victory we weren't
going to win and he did some
unbelievable things
the second half of that game but just as
mater does it make NFL scouts nervous
about somebody who is that intellectual
cerebral I would hope not I mean
goodness sakes if you spend any time
with Peyton Manning there if you spent
any time with Tom Brady you spent any
time with Drew Brees those guys are
wildly intellectual as well I mean
Peyton Manning I sat in the studio with
Marvin Harrison yesterday and how to
talk with Marvin and Marvin was talking
about how you know they couldn't get out
of meeting sometimes because Peyton is
always trying to ask why why are we
doing this I coached with Gregg Knapp
who was Peyton's quarterback coach when
they won the Super Bowl in Denver and
Greg used to tell me stories about
Payton's thirst for information and and
how he just soaked up and sucked in
information and Josh is the same way so
if it scares somebody to have an
intellectual quarterback and I would say
that that's that's an interesting theory
that I really haven't heard before
well there you know people look at the
Wonderlic and sometimes you test too
high that they feel like you know that
maybe you're not going to listen to
you're not going to be coached or you're
gonna think you know more than the coach
yeah you know you know how crazy it gets
a draft time coach we're sure oh my
goodness it's amazing everything is just
amplifying in the conjunction that the
mock drafts and the rumors it's awesome
I mean it makes for great media great
radio great television you know great
conjecture but you know Josh loves
football and there's been a question
does it is Josh love football he loves
football he's he's on record saying if I
didn't love football I wouldn't play
football you know he his family has some
means and he has intellectually things
that he could do and I think the
intellect is more important than the
means he could he could be anything he
wanted to be but he loves to play
football and the intellect I think one
of the reasons I said he needs be
intellectually stimulated and challenge
it because if you if you can't tell him
why if you can't tell anyone why it's
it's tough for them to buy it you know I
know as a coach would always fill this
position coach going into a room to
a coverage for instance as a defensive
back coach is that I really needed to
understand that coverage because of one
of my players asked me why we were doing
something I couldn't answer it then I
lost credibility and you know it I think
it's even more important nowadays with
just the weight the younger generation
wants to to to engage and I think the
intellect is a real positive especially
at that position I mean this guy he he
knows it he can see it he can feel it he
can read it it's it's really amazing
he's Jim Moore former UCLA head coach
joining us Continental Tire Coach's
Corner if you were coaching Cleveland
who would you take well I was coaching I
mean I want I'm coaching I want Josh
Rosen pulling the trigger okay but you
would have him but did now did he say
that he didn't want to go to Cleveland
do you know if that's true another that
no I you never said that to me okay what
he said yesterday I believe is that he
just wants to play in the NFL whoever
drops and he's gonna play four but I
didn't see that as a cold either I just
saw someone say that he said that I
would he hasn't told me and he just
tells me I can't wait to play at the
next level and be great so and I don't
talk to him every day that I tax or tax
with him yesterday i text with him this
weekend you know we're neighbors
I care desperately about this young man
but he knows that like what you're
saying like he understands what you're
saying I sent him a text before I we're
on the air and said that if I were if
that the Cleveland Browns should take
Sam Donald forfeit I sent Josh a tax and
I said Josh I want to let you know I'm
going on the air and I'm going to say
that this that the Cleveland Browns
should take Sam Donald forfeit because
of fit and he said okay thanks Jim he
didn't say oh my God thank you
he said you know thanks coach not it was
it was a thanks for the heads-up how I
could read it to you if you wanted was
right thanks for the heads-up it was
just very simple so I don't think at any
time and the sign
you know you hear what he says most
often that he's indicated anybody that
there's a someplace that he perverse
prefers to player doesn't want to play
these guys you're a competitor like Josh
Rosen is you ought to be the first pick
you want to be recognized as the best it
doesn't matter if you're going to any
team you want to be the first pick
that's what he's worked towards all his
life and that's the competitor in him
and I think all of these quarterbacks
believe that they can go into Cleveland
the team that's struggled and they can
work with Hugh Jackson and they can
revive that franchise I mean I believe
they're all the quarterbacks I have to
feel that way and if they don't feel
that way then you know as a organization
you don't want them well keep stirring
it up you know I am stir it up a little
bit a little bit listen I like I said it
at the outset
I've been completely clear I have been
consistent and I have been very very
very very diffusive in my praise of Josh
Rosen and that will not change because
it is the truth I love him I think he's
the best player in the draft I think
he's gonna have an immediate impact
wherever he goes I think the city's
going to love him the organization's
going to love him his players are going
to love him and I think he's going to
win and I can't wait to watch it happen
and I can't wait for all this to die
down a little bit well once we hang up
we're gonna twist your words so just so
you know I know yeah we put another
t-shirt up there like that remember this
picture says you got to start coaching
again all right I can't wait to start
coaching and hopefully I get another
opportunity so we'll have fun thanks and
have fun on the NFL Network there thank
you
that's a coach Jim Moore NFL Network's
path to the draft I think he's guilty of
being honest Mike if you can be guilty
of being honest I think that's always
doing is saying
it's not gonna fit with that Coach maybe
that gym or that system he'd probably be
better if he went to the Giants or the
Jets
you know Sam darn 'old is gonna maybe
fit better with you Jackson I think what
he's saying is that Sam darn 'old is a
Andy Dalton type quarterback I guess
that's what he's saying is it the red
hair too Yeah right
I mean come on that's not fair yes yes
McLovin by the way if Josh if Jim Moore
is saying mixed things about Josh Rosen
I want someone saying those mixed things
about me you know he's the best player
in the draft he's smart you're loved
he's gonna win a melee well kind of
scathing criticism there
I think the only part of this you know
what we'll take a break because I want
to talk a little bit more about this
Continental Tire coaches corner
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire the Dan Patrick show no
matter where you drive or what you drive
Continental designs tires for what you
do for more information visit
Continental Tire Calm Continental Tire
for what you do for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]